hey instead of a voice mail today
because we haven't had time to do this
for so long because of the election I
want to do some of my popular Instagram
pictures real quick of course I'm on
instagram at david dot pakman I picked
up the brush again I was unable to paint
for months because it just been so busy
with the election and I finally got got
my acrylic paints back out and I
actually made a painting and we can put
it up of full screen for you and it's
kind of a disaster i mean i just can't
paint well everything is in the same
sort of plane the mountains in the
background barely look like they're
further away than the individual blades
of grass in the foreground is it
possible Pat that I'm just not going to
be good at painting well I mean one of
those two things at the top there those
clouds or is that part of the mountain
not like a smiley face all together I
know it's like a smiley face cloud thing
but those are those are supposed to be
clouds and at you know what I don't know
what the hell I like it I don't know
what I'm doing also people liking that I
finally have confirmed that I do wear
warby parker glasses we've had warby
parker as an advertiser for a while on
the show and because i were my contact
lenses on the show many people were
doubtful that i actually wear warby
parker glasses in real life but the
other day i posted a picture uh where i
was actually wearing my glasses and uh
you know that's something and nearly 300
likes on that one for whatever reason i
try to post i go through all this
trouble to post interesting and unique
things to instagram and just posting a
selfie of me surprised about the next
day's stories gets more likes than
anything else right i mean that was an
interesting and unique facial expression
there so course it got a lot of
attention i am on instagram at david dot
pakman no voice mail today we are here
tomorrow the infamous day before
thanksgiving and then we'll be off for
the rest of the week on the bonus show
today I'm gonna talk to you about a
woman who gave birth in a car and the
hospital charged her the full delivery
fee anyway they said what the hell she
did get give birth so we'll still
charger the full fee and i also want to
dig into why smartphones are a big
reason that Donald Trump is unlikely to
win the trade war he sort of threatening
to wage against country
like China and lastly I want to talk
about the ability of people to
distinguish between uh shows or news and
sponsored content which is a major issue
regarding media literacy which I've
talked about for a long time if you
would like to be a member and get the
bonus show but you just can't quite
afford the normal prices we have a
coupon code I voted 17 all one word all
lower case I voted 17 which you can use
on any membership at david pakman.com
slash membership that will give you a
major major discount i invite you to use
that and join the david pakman show
family